E
DISTRICT OR BORDER POLICIES.
SENDING IT BACK TO YOU.
JON: BILL MELUGIN LIVE IN THE
RIO GRANDE VALLEY OF TEXAS.
THANK YOU.
JOINING US NOW OKLAHOMA
REPUBLICAN SENATOR JAMES
LANKFORD A MEMBER OF THE
HOMELAND AND GOVERNMENTAL
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE, FINANCE
COMMITTEE AS WELL AND YOU MADE A
NUMBER OF TRIPS TO THE BORDER.
YOU DESCRIBED AS AN EPIDEMIC.
IT IS ABOUT TO GET WORSE WITH
TITLE 42 RELAXATION.
>> IT WAS ALWAYS INTENDED TO BE
TEMPORARY BUT WHEN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION CAME IN THE HAD A
YEAR TO ESTABLISH WHAT IS NEXT
IN THE NINE YEARS THEY WORKED ON
A PLAN TO MOVE PEOPLE INTO THE
INTERIOR FASTER THERE TALKING
HOW DO I PICK PEOPLE APPEAR AT
THE BORDER AND MOVE THEM INTO
THE INTERIOR SO THERE'S ENOUGH
CHAOS, THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
STOP AND TURN IT AROUND TO
TALKING ABOUT HOW TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE IT.
AS STRANGE AS IT IS THEY SAID
THE PANDEMIC IS OVER AT THE
BORDER WITH THE MEMBERS OF THE
MILITARY ARE BEING FORCED INTO
RETIREMENT IF THEY DON'T GET THE
COVID SHOT WERE WEARING MASKS ON
PLANES AND THE ADMINISTRATION IS
REQUIRING THAT THE PICKETING
CHOOSING WHEN THE PANDEMIC IS
OVER.
JON: WHY DID THEY NOT THINK THIS
IS A CRISIS, IF THEY THOUGHT IT
WAS A CRISIS THEY WOULD STOP IT.
>> THEY SHOULD STOP IN CAN STOP
IT, THE MOST BASIC OF THINGS
WHOEVER GETS IN THE LAST PERSON
AND IS THE FIRST PERSON HERE AND
SENDS A MESSAGE ACROSS THE
BORDER ILLEGALLY, YES WE WILL
PUT YOU IN A DROUGHT AND THEN
WILL DO IT RIGHT NOW, RIGHT NOW
WHEN YOU CROSS THE BORDER YOU
GIVE IT A PIECE OF PAPER IN YOUR
ASKED WHERE WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO
IN THE COUNTRY FOR YOUR HEARING
AND THEN THEY'RE GIVEN A PIECE
OF PAPER TO GO IN THAT SPOT SIX
YEARS IN THE FUTURE, SIX YEARS
THEY'RE ALLOWED TO STAY IN THE
COUNTRY, IF YOU DO THAT YOU'RE
SENDING THE SIGNAL TO THE REST
OF THE WORLD COME TO THE UNITED
STATES YOU CAN BE HERE SIX YEARS
ILLEGALLY AND WE WILL ALLOW YOU.
>> WE HAVE NO IDEA WHO THESE
PEOPLE ARE THEY'RE NOT COMING
FROM GUATEMALA, HONDURAS IS
COMING FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD.
>> THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SAYS
WERE TALKING ABOUT ROOT CAUSES,
MIGRATION COMING IN AND THEY
FOCUS ON WHAT THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE, WE HAD PEOPLE ALL OVER
THE WORLD, LAST YEAR EVERY
SINGLE COUNTRY IN THE WORLD THAT
ILLEGALLY CROSSED THE BORDER,
THIS YEAR 150 DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES, JUST THIS YEAR
CROSSING THE BORDER, YET PEOPLE
COMING INTO LEGAL BILL FROM
EVERY COUNTRY YOU CAN NAME THIS
IS NOT JUST ABOUT ROOT CAUSES OF
THIS FITS INTO FACILITATING
ILLEGAL TRAFFICKING THE UNITED
STATES.
EVERYONE IS BETWEEN
4000 - $30000 TO THE CARTELS IN
MEXICO TO BE ABLE TO CROSS THE
BORDER AND THIS IS $10 BILLION
TO THE CARTELS IN MEXICO LAST
YEAR.
WE ARE ENRICHING THE CARTELS AND
DEVASTATING OUR COUNTRY RIGHT
NOW.
JON: DOESN'T THIS HOLD ON THE
WAGES OF AMERICAN WORKERS?
IF YOU BRING IN MILLIONS OF
ILLEGAL WORKERS RIGHT NOW,
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS DOESN'T
ESSENTIALLY KEEP PRICES LOW ON
THE WAGE SCALE?
>> IT DOES YET PEOPLE COMPETING
THAT KNOW THAT THEY CAN COMPETE
FOR WAGES AND GET EQUAL WAGES
BECAUSE THEY'RE HERE ILLEGALLY,
SOME PEOPLE SAY YOU HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT I'M PAYING YOU
I WILL TURN YOU IN.
THE OTHER ISSUE IS A CARTEL IF
YOU CAN'T PAY THE CARTEL THEY
WILL SAY WE HAVE SOMETHING YOU
COULD DO FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
PAY THAT OFF WEATHERED SEX
TRAFFICKING, DRUG TRAFFICKING,
WORKING IN SWEATSHOPS IN THE
UNITED STATES THAT IS MANAGED BY
THE CARTEL THEY HAVE WAYS THAT
THEY CAN PAY OFF THEIR DEBT AS
WELL, THAT IS ALSO DRAMATIC THIS
IS FACILITATING ILLEGAL ACTIVITY
AND HURTING OUR ECONOMY AND
PEOPLE.
JON: THE VICE PRESIDENT IS
SUPPOSED TO BE IN CHARGE OF THE
PORTFOLIO UNDER BORDER PART OF
HER PORTFOLIO BUT IT DOESN'T
SEEMED LIKE ANYBODY IS TRYING TO
GET THEIR ARMS AROUND THIS
CRISIS.
>> PEOPLE FORGET WHEN BIDEN WAS
VICE PRESIDENT HE WAS ALSO
ASSIGNED TO MANAGE ROOT CAUSES
OF MIGRATION HE WAS ALSO GOING
DOWN TO CENTRAL AMERICA, HE
BECOMES PRESIDENT POSITIVE VICE
PRESIDENT WE SEE THE SAME
QUALITY OF JOB BEING DONE NOW AS
WHEN HE WAS VICE PRESIDENT AS
WELL THEY ARE NOT DEALING WITH
THIS AND THE PEOPLE IN CENTRAL
AMERICA THAT I MET WITH SAY OVER
AND OVER STOP ENCOURAGING PEOPLE
TO COME TO THE UNITED STATES BY
HAVING OPEN BORDER, THEIR LABOR
FORCES ARE LEAVING WHICH IS
HURTING THEIR ECONOMY AND THEIR
COUNTRY AND SAYING WHAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS DOING NOW IS
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO LEAVE
THEIR ECONOMY, COME TO OUR
ECONOMY IS HURTING OUR NATION
AND HURTING THERE'S.
>> TO THINK THE WHITE HOUSE DOES
NOT WANT TO STOP THE PROBLEM
BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE SEEN AS
ENDORSING WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
DID?
>> EVERYTHING THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING IS A FAR
FAR LEFT WEATHER ENVIRONMENTAL
POLICY WITH OIL AND GAS IN THE
UNITED STATES AND WILL BUY FROM
RUSSIA OR VENEZUELA OR WHETHER
MIGRATION ISSUE HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW, THEY ARE TERRIFIED OF THE
FAR LEFT PROGRESSIVES WERE OPEN
BORDER AND SAY OPEN THE BORDER
ANYTIME THEY ENFORCE THE BORDER
THE FAR LEFT START SCREAMING AND
THEY KOWTOW TO THE MANY GETS
WORSE.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT KETANJI
BROWN JACKSON, THE VOTE LIKELY
TO BE THIS WEEK IN THE UNITED
STATES SENATE, WHAT IS YOUR
VOTE?
>> I WILL VOTE NO SEVERAL
PROCEDURAL VOTES STARTING
TOMORROW MONDAY, TUESDAY AND
THURSDAY THE FINAL VOTE COULD BE
THURSDAY, SHE AND I MET ON
THURSDAY, WE HAD A LONG MEETING
VERY PLEASANT TO TALK TO AND
SOMEONE YOU WOULD ENJOY SITTING
DOWN TO DINNER BUT SOMEONE I
CANNOT SUPPORT TO BE ON THE
SUPREME COURT.
WE HAVE DISAGREEMENTS ON THE
ROLE OF THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH OF
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH AND
SENTENCING REQUIREMENTS SEVERAL
OTHER ISSUES BUT SHE'S A
PLEASANT PERSON YOU CAN'T NEGATE
THAT AT ALL BUT THIS IS A VERY
SERIOUS ISSUE WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT HOW YOU CAN INTERPRET THE
LAW AND HOW IT'S GOING TO BE
IMPLIED.
JON: IF YOU GET EVERY DEMOCRAT
VOTE, SHE IS GOING TO WIN THAT
APPOINTMENT AND THERE IS ONE
REPUBLICAN SENATOR WHO SAID SHE
WOULD VOTE YES.
>> EVERY DEMOCRAT VOTES THEN
SHE'S PUT ON THE COURT, THERE'S
NO WAY WE CAN STOP IT THE SAME
WAY THE DEMOCRATS WERE UPSET
WITH THE PRETRIAL NUMBERING ONTO
NOMINEES BUT THERE IS NO WAY
THEY CAN STOP THOSE THREE
NOMINEES IN THE PROCESS THAT THE
REPUBLICAN VOTED FOR.
WHEN WE PUT THOSE INDIVIDUALS ON
THE COURT THEN THIS'LL BE THE
SAME AS WHAT THEY'RE DEALING
WITH AS WELL.
THIS IS WHY ELECTIONS MATTER.
JON: IT DOES NOT CHANGE THE
IDEOLOGICAL BALANCE OF THE COURT
IF PRIOR ON THE LIBERAL SIDE IS
GOING TO VOTE PRIMARILY THE SAME
WAY HE HAS WOULD YOU NOT SAY?
>> SHE CLERKED FOR JUDGE BREYER
SO SHE'S BEEN MEANT TOWARD BY
HIM AND HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE SHE HAD GREAT EXPERIENCE
AND BACKGROUND IN EVERY
EXPECTATION ON HOW SHE'S
HANDLING THE SENSITIVE LAW AND
JUDGE BREYER SHALL BE MAKING
DECISIONS VERY CONSISTENT FROM
THE LEFT-WIN